we are used to thinking about markets
for goods and services and demand and
supply of goods and services and what
we're going to do in this video is
broaden our sense of what a market could
be for by thinking about the market for
loanable funds
now this might seem like a very
technical term loanable funds but it
literally just means funds that people
are supplying to be lent out to other
people and funds that people are
demanding that they want to borrow and
so one way to think about this market
the suppliers
in the loanable funds market
these are the savers
so when you go and save some money maybe
at a bank that bank will then lend that
money to someone else and because the
bank is getting interest from that
person they can also afford to pay you
some interest so you get a return it
doesn't always have to be through a bank
but that tends to be typical it'll go
through some type of intermediary
similarly who are the demanders or where
is the demand coming from i don't know
if demanders is a real word but i'll
just write it down so where is the
demand coming from well that is coming
from the borrowers
who are interested in maybe making an
investment maybe some type of business
opportunity is available to them and as
i mentioned this isn't a market where
the suppliers and the demanders or the
savers and the borrowers necessarily
directly interact with each other every
now and then you might get a loan from
your sister-in-law or from from your
parents but oftentimes usually it's
going through some type of institution
some type of financial institution
usually banks where the savers put their
money in a bank hoping not just for safe
keeping but really to get a return on
their money in order to provide a return
to those savers the bank will then lend
it out to borrowers and charge interest
to them and to appreciate this in the
way that we've looked at markets before
i can set up
two axes
and in any market that we've looked at
before the horizontal axis this is the
quantity and so here we're talking about
the quantity
of loanable funds
loanable
funds
and then on the vertical axis we
normally think about the price for the
good or service but when we're dealing
with loanable funds the price is the
interest rate and if we want to know the
real price we should be talking about
the real interest rate
real
interest
rate
and so let's think about each of these
scenarios let's think about the savers
who are really the suppliers in the
loanable funds market
when real interest rates are lower if
real interest rates are low they don't
want to really supply a lot of quantity
they're not getting not a lot of
motivation to be a supplier to save in
that situation but if real interest
rates are high well then they might say
hey i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm more likely
to save and i want to leave make my
funds available for loaning out to other
people because i get this great interest
rate especially it's a real interest
rate so we could view it as something
like this this we could call our supply
of loanable funds
and you can imagine what the demand
curve for loanable funds looks like when
real interest rates are high people say
hey you know there aren't that many
business opportunities that could
justify borrowing at that high of a rate
so there wouldn't be much quantity that
is demanded but as the real interest
rates or if the real interest rates are
lower as they get lower then the
quantity demanded of loanable funds will
be higher
so this is our demand for loanable funds
and like we've seen in the past you're
going to have an equilibrium quantity
and price where price in this situation
is your real interest rate
and so that's going to happen where
these intersect this is our equilibrium
quantity
and this is our equilibrium
real interest rate
now let's think about what would happen
if one or both of these curves were to
shift somehow and there's a couple of
ways let's start with the demand for
loanable funds there's a couple of ways
that the demand for loanable funds curve
could shift maybe all of a sudden people
see new business opportunities asteroid
mining is becoming a thing and so people
want to borrow money to get robots and
send them out into space so they can
mine asteroids for platinum or something
well what would happen pause this video
and think about that
well then at any given real interest
rate there's going to be a higher
quantity demanded
so in that situation our demand for
loanable funds would shift to the right
it would look something like this so
this is demand for loanable funds i'll
call it sub 2. sometimes you'll see
something like a prime there but i'll
call it sub 2. so it has shifted to the
right because of new business
opportunities another common reason why
that might shift to the right is if
maybe the government is doing a lot more
borrowing remember this is an aggregate
market here so the the government when
it borrows money to fuel its spending
that also it has to go into the loanable
funds market and so increased government
borrowing would also shift this to the
right and if the opposite happened if
people thought there were fewer business
opportunities or if the government
started to borrow less well that would
shift things to the left but let's just
think about what would happen
if r what is the current equilibrium
interest rate if that just stayed where
what is well then you're going to have a
shortage of loanable funds where the
suppliers would be willing to supply
this quantity while the borrowers are
going to want this quantity here at that
real interest rate and so what you're
going to have happen is you're going to
get to a new equilibrium point the real
interest rate is going to go up to this
point let's call that
our new equilibrium real interest rate
and
our quantity is going to go up as well
so q1 in order to get in order to be
convinced more suppliers to part with
their not part with their money or at
least make their money available for
lending well the interest rate's going
to have to go up and we get to that
point right there
similarly you could have shifts in the
supply of loanable funds
let's say for example the savings rate
changes for some reason there's a big
marketing campaign and from the
government or in education or in schools
that say hey we need to save more for a
rainy day you need to save more for
retirement well then the supply of
loanable funds if everyone saves more at
any given real interest rate well then
the supply for loanable funds curve
could shift to the right and if the
opposite happened of course it would
shift to the left supply of loanable
funds to and then what would happen well
if we were at this point right over here
all of a sudden we are in a situation
where there's a surplus of loanable
funds at this interest rate people are
willing to supply way more loanable
funds than people are demanding so then
the price of the loanable funds which is
the real interest rate will go down
it will go down to this new equilibrium
point and so here this we could call
this
r sub 3 would be our new real interest
rate equilibrium real interest rate and
this would be our new equilibrium
quantity actually let me call this r sub
2 right over here
so i will leave you there the big
takeaway is is that loanable funds kind
of operate the way the market for most
anything would with the difference being
that the price is no longer just a
dollar amount it is an interest rate and
since we want to factor out inflation it
is a real interest rate